you heard it here first love you cheetos
yeah you're my side chick this is the
main one lo siento
hey what's up everybody my name is
gabriel iglesias that's gabriela
if you can say it right and you're about
to see some of my favorite
mexican snacks why because he's mexican
and it makes sense
[Music]
all right this first one right here this
is called
duvalin this right here i want to say is
like a it's an 18 pack
it's a lot it says 18 this yocho psas
that's 18 pieces
you're getting a little education here
not only are you learning about certain
snacks and candies you're also learning
a
new language it's like rosetta stone but
it's free as you can see
it's like it's like when you go to vegas
and it comes with all these little mini
shovels
so you take one and you break it off and
then you
have your little pack oh he caught it
caught it see that yes
oh okay so these are not like
traditional american candies that are
usually real easy to open and enjoy but
it's made with real sugar and the
packaging is a little bit different
so let's give this a give this a try
right here it's a little chocolate a
little bit of vanilla
and it's all good there's nothing that
tastes like this here in the united
states and believe me
i've had it all oh yeah i'm a little
candy hoe
i have had it all this is very thick
it's very rich
and again you could taste the sugar
believe me i'm diabetic i know
get my it's going to go down do i lean
people
[Music]
this next one right here this one's uh a
very a big time personal favorite these
are takis
i know some people have called them
takis or takai's
we call them takis in the neighborhood
and uh basically these were the answer
to the uh hot cheetos there's hot
cheetos and then there's like
literally fire in your mouth these
things are incredible and the sad part
is
they make them in like hot hotter and
then freaking call your doctor because
it's gonna hurt tomorrow
i love these very very much you don't
even have to pay me to say that but you
can
you can make the check payable to
gabriel iglesias um and i will cash it
and
and i'll buy more takis with it these
are so good and let me tell you guys as
a lover of spicy food because i am in
fact a lover of spicy food i love spice
a lot of spice and everything nice i in
fact have a hot sauce
it's called tapatio it's it's not mine
but
i'm like good friends with the company
special edition guess who's on the
bottle this month oh
what that's right i'm featured here with
my dogs i have two little dogs and uh
even though they don't eat uh spicy food
they're spicy dogs
oh man let me tell you guys something
okay so we've seen we've seen takis
we've seen dubalinas we've seen all
kinds of other snacks that uh
that mexican folks like myself nos
gustan with uh stuff that we enjoy that
we love
this has to be easily top three i know
they're called it says de la rosa i've
never referred to them as de la rosa
i call these masapanas they're basically
it's a
mexican reese's peanut butter cup
without the chocolate it's
peanuts condensed into this little tiny
mexican hockey puck right here with the
little rose on it and um
the trick has always been can you
successfully
open it without breaking it are you
delicate
and gentle enough to open up a masapan
nope i already broke it
see that basically you kind of just take
out the busted pieces
you smell it mmm peanuts
no no you just throw it i'm so good i
definitely grew up on these as a kid
this was always like a big treat to get
one of these if you got one of these
somebody got paid a check cleared
somebody sold something
you don't just get these these are not
cheap and so
yeah these are a big time celebration
whenever we can get our hands on one
masapanas you guys
[Music]
all right i know we got like we're
talking about mexican candies and stuff
and you're like but hey
what's up with this there's like
japanese writing on this one in the hood
we call these kakawattes
haponesis basically it's a
it's a peanut and it's like a like a
like a hard
hard shell i'm not even gonna call it a
candy shell it's just like a hard shell
around the peanut
and it's uh spicy you know on the
weekends there's a big fight going on
people are cracking beers and what are
we going to eat with the beer
and somebody would pull one of these out
and you could always hear people eating
it they're really loud you eat it as a
they're crunchy you can usually find
them up
i would say at a 7-eleven or something
convenience store like that if it's a
7-eleven like in the hood hood
it's got to be a hood hood not like
calabasas it's got to be like straight
up like
you know when you park your car you're
like i don't know if that shit's going
to be there when i get back
that's that's that's where you're going
to find these these japanese
peanuts good stuff people
good stuff ladies and gentlemen boys and
girls children of all ages let me
introduce you
to my friend sabritones sabritones
say it with me people uh it's basically
kind of like a ghetto version of
pork rinds chicharrones pigskin um
i don't even think that's what they're
made of um honestly but
it looks like it and hey if it looks
like it it probably is
these are super good i i've been
enjoying these for
god like 20 years at least when you eat
too many of these your mouth will
shrivel up because the amount of salt
that's in them so you got to always have
something to drink because you eat and
your mouth just kind of it turns into
like that yeah my mouth's gonna look
like a chicken butt but these are really
really good
i really have a couple memories right
here ah
smells good usually with these you would
add like lemon you take like a bunch of
lemon you just squeeze them in there
and then you glue like this and then put
some hot sauce inside and
shake it up and i've had the opportunity
of enjoying these
for again many many years so good
well you guys uh we've pretty much
reached the end of this uh this has been
snacked
i've been gabrielle iglesias and we've
enjoyed ourselves and
this is fun this is it's not every day
you get invited to come and enjoy and
just eat and
drink and and try new things so uh
you know big shout out to you guys for
letting me do that here today and uh
yeah this
this has been snack so much fun
[Music]
you